[Music]
Toy Story 3 had a magnificent ending and
every fan was satisfied with the
supposed finale of the series but things
turned out differently and another movie
followed nine years later Toy Story 4
was released and broke all attendance
records the story was mediocre but they
had at least found a worthy ending for
Woody Buzz and their friends once again
however Disney seems to have other plans
as Toy Story 5 was announced this spring
no one knows exactly how the story will
continue since the toy friends actually
parted ways at the end of the fourth
part but there are already some very
interesting theories circulating on the
internet about how the story could
continue and we've summarized the best
ones for you in this video
Toy Story 5 offers plenty of
opportunities for the creators but they
are also associated with risks the focus
could be on new toys or on already
established ones like Jesse however it's
the friendship between Woody and Buzz
that made the first four movies into the
classics they are doing without them
would run the risk of losing the old
fans well luckily they have confirmed
that the duo will be back Tim Allen also
announced via Twitter that he will once
again provide Buzz's voice
one Theory revolves around the
protagonist's past Toy Story 5 could
partly function as a prequel with
multiple storylines in Toy Story 2. we
already learned quite a bit about
Woody's earlier life and light year
dealt with the buzz character's Origins
but of course there is much more to
discover such as who would his first
owner was while this Narrative Approach
would open up entirely new worlds for us
it could also become too complex for the
family-friendly franchise
each movie in the Toy Story franchise
introduced at least one new toy and
sometimes more than one be it Jesse and
Bullseye who appear in Andy's room in
Toy Story 2 or 4K whom Bonnie created in
Toy Story 4. the latter even got his own
series on Disney plus so it would be
entirely possible to make a completely
new storyline in which the earlier
protagonist would only have a minor role
however chances are high that fans will
criticize such an attempt we have
already experienced this in the 2022
film light year where Disney substituted
the voice of Tim Allen with that of
Chris Evans which did not go down well
at all with the fans still a 4K Centric
plot would be a possibility for example
similar things have already been done
before for example in Shrek with the
Puss in Boots films and then Frozen with
the short films of Olaf it remains
unclear however whether Forkey really
has what it takes to replace Woody and
Buzz
many people are unaware that Toy Story 2
was originally supposed to have a
completely different storyline moreover
the original plot of Toy Story 3 was
scrapped when Disney tried to distance
itself from Pixar at the time they gave
control of the Toy Story franchise to
the now defunct company Circle 7
animation Toy Story 5 could therefore
resume the actual plot of Toy Story 2.
this one centered on a malfunction of
Andy's Buzz Lightyear action figure that
results in the toy being shipped to
Taiwan where he encounters other Star
Command toys this idea doesn't seem so
far-fetched given the introduction of
other Star Command members in light year
if they're trying to make a connection
to the spin-off film
Bonnie was never really able to make up
for the void left by Andy in Toy Story 4
with fans many couldn't believe their
eyes when he handed over his toys to the
girl in Toy Story 3 and headed off to
college so in Toy Story 5 this very
storyline could be Revisited Andy could
return and take back his toys perhaps
not to play with them himself but he
could leave them to his children Woody
Buzz and Friends bringing a family
together doesn't that sound like a very
heartwarming and fitting storyline for
the franchise
the 2022 movie light year flopped at the
box office however it did manage to
finally tell us the background story of
Buzz at the beginning of the movie it
was revealed that this movie was
actually the reason why Andy Davis fell
in love with the Space Ranger in 1995
and desperately wanted his action figure
Toy Story 5 could take a similar path
the film could be Woody's Roundup
starring Woody Jesse the prospector and
Bullseye that would be the movie Andy's
dad saw that made him want a cowboy
Woody doll so badly images of Woody's
Roundup can be seen over and over again
in the Toy Story movies one problem here
however would be to include Buzz's part
he would then probably appear more on
the sidelines for example as a narrator
Pixar has always shown a talent for
emotional endings Parts 3 and 4 are the
prime examples here the moviegoers were
always left with tears in their eyes
that's why we expect a touching ending
for Toy Story 5 as well we are
particularly fond of a little fan
fiction imagine the toys Changing Hands
again as part of the new adventure then
at the end of the movie The mother of
the new child would show up and notice
that these toys look just like the ones
he had as a kid of course this would be
none other than Andy this ending would
definitely have tear-jerking potential
and would once again provide a nice
conclusion to the film series
those were the most interesting theories
around Toy Story 5. which one do you
think is the best or do you even have
one in mind that we haven't thought of
yet let us know in the comments
[Music]